[Music]
I'm Beryl this week we're gonna be
looking at noodles by the way I'm not my
parents house exhibit a Exhibit B
exhibit my dog hi my mom's dog oh it's
so hot it is way too hot I'm not gonna
be cooking I'm just gonna give you some
facts and we'll get into the story okay
so in 2005 archaeologists in China
uncovered a bowl of noodles that was
4,000 years old this solidified China as
the birthplace of noodles from China
it's believed that nomadic Arabs a
nomadic Arabs travelling East brought
the dish across the Middle East and into
Europe and since then noodles have gone
global
from fideos in Mexico to ramen in Japan
vermicelli in the Middle East every
country has its own interpretation there
is no way that I could cover every
noodle from every country it's just not
possible you would be watching this
video forever I could however cover
seven so I spoke to seven people who
make seven different noodles in seven
countries to see the different
iterations around the world so this is
the noodle episode in making this
episode I decided two things one I'm not
doing instant noodles that is a whole
other episode and if you want that one
let me know
and two the noodles should be handmade
so I'm not gonna go to factories for
this one and I do want to say one more
thing quickly a lot of the noodles that
you're gonna see have different names in
different countries and I am NOT saying
that one is more right than the other I
just happen to film in the countries
that I filmed in so if you see a noodle
from your country by a different name
leave a comment and let us know what it
is called where you live knowledge is
power
noodle knowledge is power okay let's
begin
as it SS my member Lynch pets limit our
velocities in Amish Canton and these a
new commissioner eminent hamara Emma
villainous in Commissioner in fact an
original file Indianola Kenosha my
sister Delano today tempest Queen de una
past antica a caliber llamo solo Anwar
Oh nonsense when you come your son by
tofu yo Leon pile of food to swim in
know that hey even I don't know I'm like
nah I'm good man I'm unofficially people
think Maggie's noodles of India but
idiyappam is traditional noodle of India
when moment awareness Amla when paired
with here the grass here is Paul Savola
Robson care if suppose five lynnium
Italians of Mercy in a beer netic that
if Bailey was it a blue dog will begin
in China here many cities have their own
noodle recipes meaning there are over
1000 different types of noodles in the
country
[Music]
i dnt patchiness locations can Walla
Walla Angolan Yamaguchi mental torture
she watches her might also mean motor
Lempicka estate Oh Charlie - so my
motion descent Oleson synonym
[Music]
institution CUDA in women is Rehan en
toda y para la rocca life Yaffa haunted
Alysha chose naga young to chee-chaw
chee-chaw chee-chaw chee-chaw chee-chaw
chee-chaw souls nama signal a hotel
finally publish Anisha Shinyoung returns
anguishes Tyson Council
from a woman it's la la da da da Suman
la única Tateyama patio so means such as
tsunami mean that solution call a woman
so mentally CEO Jonah it is done by Tony
Anissa to say it entitles open so here
it's totally not intentionally what can
you do to the house next is a rice
noodle out of Thailand where the process
for making it is becoming a lost art go
[Music]
to routine coop anything up around town
putting thigh and I'll go way to convene
problem to some pet : a couple thousand
aluminum and got something someone say
to me Oh take a shower my boy turns out
but he containment it'd be moving
normally fun been gone Bobby team open
because leg on my thumb just a couple
told me I got to work cuddling tipper
but the payment to be dope man you
definitely know you look look see a
diamond girl happened see more robust I
don't son copied up incommunicado I
don't buy my public opinion Celia deep
our faces I see diamond infinity me what
no connection to work until gangam Det
mark and some nipple midnight by Tokyo
cooler behind I'm I can button is
probability do this tiene una Nina hi MA
hi : a family a glare quanto primary
Andrew
[Music]
next up is German spaetzle the word
spaetzle comes from the Swabian word
meeting little sparrows thank you
[Music]
and diversity noodley my name is uber
Markov kind of listing Spetses on an ear
hair conditioner my name is matthew
eledge commerce baleen his master's
better Zeb's sight image from Sol
stomping on manny mota the English
Reformation specimen Dalton affair
glossary Newton Bob I'm animal head west
side in elections or dominant eye
Gonzalez so ass comes meal and I go
through so that's who come FIFA first
kid ignore most cards on sides thus
cancer but with iron on Minerva's of
ferment Dan Berta's consider lured mr.
tight glass and select the type salt a
few ministers and iris from the rule the
tyke but in the entire game won't direct
in a score another second of it Spezza
isn't fetish Sebastiani was over flesh
yeah Xmas turnabout to kizamu see Sonya
and the EMTALA zones for the constants
which dish yet seat Naha in akiza better
unified which medicine that was dicker
atomized new hair Commission Newland
entourage in North adverse Forester the
community owners invite spaetzle I'm
crafting Kaiser want English wants
feeble aside from the obvious liquor
our investment I'll to see it as our
phobia
[Music]
keeping in Europe this noodle is one of
the rarest in the world a laurel
apostasy qiyamah souville in deo Kesari
Baro afield I do in to Tosa Ramona -
inna de persona que lo sabemos far a
total mondo mio Nome é para brawny Midd
questa pasta Casey qiyamah souville
Indio
che lavoro da ultra quieren carne o
Imperato zu villain do da me ostrich era
el curso de Leon E Oh circuit OD
professional Latin fatty
URI ESCO down arrow to lean OD pasta add
open area chain touch of Pontus a Philly
tal meant a shorty like a solo for
Salonika carry a safari cuesta mucho
chapattis a filly ingrediente del feelin
do so no same ol Alegre new duro aqua
sally quinn do projeto conquest Oh
movimiento de lemony
Toby plague Ola la pasta paratha volt a
in modo de cría request a Philly show
till I see me da da Jason fondo de línea
top OD Cosima today sacar el sol cuando
una bella giornata puree a casa al
entero de la casa temperature ambient a
windy - volley tempo a repeater episode
a non chamber canary okay La Paz Oprah
Dora el secreto Cinelli money
La Paz Adele cylinder vital mint a
delicate I'm a proponent businesses are
Lapera per capital gusto que que Presta
pasta you might not think about noodles
when you think about Indian cuisine or
maybe you think about Maggie but they
have actually been around since the 5th
century
this dish my mother used to do very
early my name is Santa and I live in
Bengaluru today I am going to make rice
idiyappam it is also known as no put
movements it is threaded up then put a
nice it is made up of rice take rice
floor mix it with little bit of salt add
water then make a bow out of it put it
in media palm press grease it with a
plate then you press it properly then
steam it texture it is looks like bread
type and it is very soft we can eat edia
Pompey chutney and with sugar and with
the stew because rice is grown in Kerala
it's a its staple food in Kerala it is
very important to our culture I love
that food very much and I see that I
make it at home the word laksa is the
Russian word for noodle and they become
popular because of the ability to dry
them and store them this is a long cold
Russian winters
[Music]
relatively near laksa a 10-year person
is Kannada course car blue des prés
Lovera CEO mr. Castelli tenacity poor
Kaka resist ally with bigotry is Japan I
wrote Mennella boochi boochi hora yeah a
Volvo register open new arrest Yaga told
amassed eh no option predator Linea
Samuel option Amato Calatrava petal
option coded mukham z TM Adam a senior
at son Stoughton version of diamond
además de yada per day yo-yos is sweet
monkey Evening Standard Arabic toka
hablando de Bona school catch a tuna
Venetian and mr. solicitor castration
love shrimp basket ability esta of
[ __ ] when he listed the TV producer
Potomac Scrooge avoid Irizarry na
charity not oniy on critical policy HK
is a temporal mm ninotchka
Appling Amasa clear who called you on
purgatory no angry bleep it was a pansy
Lee who sweetie love she Nightly News
Lee who's a taalib see an effeminate
gift from rated octopus - Milania a Bob
became a visible and yet CPU mischief
[Music]
final noodle is a rice little out of
Vietnam that has become a family
business Oh team Magnum yeah no yeah
nicknamed buddy
kill the Magnum move my buddy Hank I'm
your army and computing gong whang Adama
telegram in Tamil a movie in America
that oh yeah yeah Union go ah la movie
um happy yeah
[Music]
okay I'm going to bring you had a lady
named I'm Magno llama the our manumana
thing boom Lompoc
bah blah champ you know I've been taking
shopping already I mean my god I'm
dangling above young lights and Bob Mayo
with anything
lemon pie like a tiara be good when I'm
hoping that oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
know I'm going I'm Taeyang well I'm
mighty a magnet a bank that triangle but
um I know you're never gonna call up oh
and don't hang ambling and at the window
there you have taken long have the gun
kata I think it's interesting how within
the seven noodle dishes that we saw the
ingredients are more or less the same
you know obviously there's some
interpretations there but it's the
execution that makes them so different
and yet we can definitely say that
noodles are universal and we are one
world united by our love of them bubbles
come at us they're all on us a mobile
show oh boy did he stand there honest
alone
we put Priya I see Boyd knows a yeast
soap still EDT
he the marsh Niall up shop graduated
idiyappam is dismayed with the love of
mom I mean I was a child my mother
grandmother they all used to prepare by
seeing it and then I learned West
apostasy Thurmond Adama dream philia
komui pero él siempre una tradición de
familia que no se te amo a tener el
Familia Nunez eastern ultra parcel mondo
coma questa Pat Slaven Islam I used to I
am a guest on here Familia has a nice
concept
besides Lika look bad or am the gonna
the
I'm looking Gong Moo hey my bad already
happening in tagging banca Eureka
God or what funny thing gonna be
anything with econ king of entire Lankan
clinic open with it is I'm can apartment
Chanyeol a woman to wrinkled countenance
under water means Champa Min Ho - ha
it's tight so more or syllable mean that
Aaron can't you hang out so what can
enhance the ha
[Music]
[Music]